hey David do you see the offensive new
use of nuclear weapons happening during
your lifetime okay this question could
we could go on for an hour about this
but to sort of sum up my view I'm going
to take a sort of naive perspective I
admit it might be naive I don't think we
will see the use of offensive nuclear
weapons during my lifetime now when I
say this I don't mean that there will be
no offensive use of extremely powerful
weapons during my lifetime what I mean
is more of a technological argument
which is that dirty bombs that are far
less powerful than nukes as well as
biochemical warfare and even cyber
attacks are going to allow for some of
the same objectives that nuking a
country might allow for a show of force
an attempt to either attack or or make
political points or whatever show
strength dominance without damaging huge
swathes of land via radiation making
them unusable in addition to the
physical killing of countless people and
in the 21st century in the 22nd century
it increasingly seems to me that those
are going to be the types of warfare
that are fought I mean look at how much
warfare has already changed over the
last 40 years even with the advent of
drone warfare wit and and so many other
technologies that I think it's much more
likely that we would see a dirty bomb
maybe detonated that we would see
biochemical warfare used to the same
crippling effect as a nuclear weapon
conceivably could but I see the
continued use of nukes to say look we
have nukes you can't nuke us but it's
hard to imagine a nation going so rogue
that they say we're going to destroy a
huge part of the world now you may hear
me say this and say David that's exactly
what people thought before the u.s.
twice used nuclear weapons and I agree
with you and I may well be wrong in 50
years this video we may watch it and say
boy how wrong was David but I think it's
more likely that we will see the
offensive you
of biochemical attacks potentially a
dirty bomb and cyber if you disagree
with me let me know we've got a great
bonus show for you today and so much
other great stuff happening next week